so let's say you're a teenager and when
you're not busy with school or hanging
out with your friends you're helping run
multiple Rainbow six siege cheating
websites out of your bedroom you know
you shouldn't be doing it but hey for a
kid in high school the money's pretty
great but now you need to tell your mom
to hire a lawyer because you piss off
the developer of the game
it's suing you so you've assualt the
suing for people including a minor for
allegedly running multiple websites that
help you launch DDoS attacks on sieges
servers so in the lawsuit the minor is
referred to as BR in order to protect
his identity and we'll get to him in
just a minute so a distributed denial of
service or DDoS attack is when one
person or a group of people overload
whatever server the game is playing on
by sending it tons and tons of random
information all at once and because the
server can't handle all of the
information being thrown at it the game
in this case siege legs severely or
crashes all together Oh No did he did he
does the server is already shown if you
dot the server let me get my kill god
damn it no wait wait wait we're still
here
I got your baby oh my god no the guy's
definitely [ __ ] with the server now
one outcome of a DDoS attack doesn't
crash the server entirely it just makes
it so that you literally can't do
anything
I'm like yeah hey hey there go and the
other more severe outcome is when the
server crashes entirely and you're
kicked from the game servers my switch
proposed hit and if you've ever played a
game where multiplayer is the focus
you've probably experienced a DDoS
attack even if you didn't know that's
what it was
now the ddossing websites that Ubisoft
names in the lawsuit offered tiered
plans and different subscription
services on the cheap end there's a
starter pack type deal for like $11
American which lets you launch one DDoS
attack at a time and gives you access to
their servers for 30 days on the
expensive end is what they refer to as
the full Bauder plan which allegedly
gives you access to a VIP network
letting you launch 3 DDoS attacks at
once and giving you lifetime access to
the server for roughly $300 America and
according to the lawsuit
Ubisoft believes that the minor BR was
responsible for quote operating updating
maintaining and supporting the website
r6d dot-com by which the defendants
provided their DDoS services and closed
and on top of that Ubisoft also believes
that this kid was quote a reseller of
the DDoS services meaning that he
collects and processes payments for
their DDoS services end quote
wellyou've Asafa suing these specific
websites and people because of their
connection to siege there's a ton of
idiot-proof software out there that's
literally clicking drop-down menus in
order to launch an attack like seriously
just just google it and it's not like
DDoS attacks happen to every once in a
while in siege it was a goddamn epidemic
reddit was flooded with people
complaining about it and siege content
creators we're talking about it non-stop
todays sign of the apocalypse people are
actually ddossing video game servers and
it's something that's happening quite
often and sieved it's it's something
that's been happening for a while but it
really spiked with the new season and
while I was bad on PC right
siege was nearly unplayable on console
for a little while
ddossing long console is out of control
right now and I have literally hundreds
of people reaching out to me every day
since the start of Operation amber eyes
so after months of these dudes Hawking
cheating subscriptions Ubisoft had
enough and decided they needed to shut
this [ __ ] down and just to be clear in
the United States ddossing an individual
a website or in this case a games server
is super illegal like a five hundred
thousand dollar fine and potentially ten
years in jail illegal and so
understanding all of that it makes sense
why you visage would decide to take such
drastic measures but back in September
of 2019 before you Basava sided to sue
these guys and these websites into
oblivion they announced in a blog post
that they were trying out a few other
solutions first they banned a bunch of
accounts scaled back how many games were
played on each server and removed the
mid-match punishment for leaving since
if you get ddosed you can't really do
anything about it
DDoS and our next steps
Ubisoft is actually taking action
against DDoS errs and this is the
hilarious but also scary aspect of
[ __ ] with a company like Ubisoft
because in an updated blog post Ubisoft
announced because of the preventive
measures they put in place DDoS attacks
were down 93% and that taking these
dudes to Corp was them tying up loose
ends tying up loose ends what are they
gonna whack these guys
sorry we're late now while we know that
Ubisoft is suing them we don't actually
know for how much there is one line in
the lawsuit that says quote the amount
in controversy exceeds the sum or value
of $75,000 but outside of that it's the
standard Ubisoft is owed monetary
damages and they don't specify how much
that is and this isn't the first time
that you basalt that's gone buckwild on
people trying to screw with siege back
in November around the same time that
they were dealing with this ddossing
fiasco they also sued a company called
Mizzou soft now Mizzou soft offered
their own cheating subscription and you
basalt found out about them after the
founder went on the BBC and showed a
journalist how to execute those cheats
we did a whole video on the situation
now the guys being sued this time
actually saw it coming and the way
they've reacted oh it's kind of insane
so according to the lawsuit they created
a fake notice that they put on their
website saying that the authorities and
Ubisoft had shut them down but in
reality that hadn't happened yet and
then they tweeted at Ubisoft from an
account associated with one of the
websites being sued making fun of the
fact that they were caught now because
this was such a big problem for such a
long time
the r6 community is actually really
happy that you've a soft is doing
something about it and if you think
about it this could be a giant PR risk
for Ubisoft to sue someone let alone a
minor or something like this but this
was such a big problem that the r6
community was like [ __ ] it man go get
them to suing the miners seem a little
drastic yeah maybe but these legal
actions are helping solve the problem
and they're helping save the health of
the game so go get them ok ok listen I
haven't played in two weeks that's an
excuse and I'm in sober one so I don't
know what you're expecting us
I'm gonna [ __ ] launch a DDoS so I can
get up a silver one that's why I use
that part